we make way for Rich Eisen the NFL
Network host and host of the Rich Eisen
show on DirecTV the audience network
also the host of the NFL 100 all-time
team that series airs Friday at 8:00
p.m. Eastern along with Chris
Collinsworth and Bill Belichick and the
list of finalists will be revealed
tonight on ESPN rich good morning what's
been the most surprising reaction to the
list so far I've had a surprising
reaction I guess would because I was
expecting people to say wow that's
that's that's until a Belichick is home
I thought that I get that and and I knew
the certain you know people that most
would have an issue with the running
backs list not having a single player
who played their entire career in the
21st century on it that the player of
the running backs group of all 12 to
have stepped off the field most recently
was Emmitt Smith so and he's been in the
Hall of Fame for quite some time now so
I was expecting all that and I don't
know I'm just I'm just thrilled the
people have really gotten into it
certainly with the with the show airing
on a Friday night so it was great to
shoot DP we we did it at NFL Films back
in May
you know how NFL Films can do great work
when they have two days to turn
something around they had six months
this is have this in the Edit Bay so
it's just been great and I'm fired up
that it's finally here
how do you think history is going to
look back on Frank Gore's career I think
people will look back on it and saying
why isn't he in the Hall of Fame you
know I hope he does get in I think he
deserves it but he's he wasn't on any
commercials he's not the guy that's the
go-to guy by the media afterwards he's a
soft-spoken dude who just keeps going
and in the era in which the 30-something
running back is supposed to be cast
aside and no longer effective he just
keeps doing it he still is the last
thousand yard rusher for the
Indianapolis Colts and
we're not even talking about the 49ers
who for whom he had a 100-yard rushing
and touchdowns a min the Super Bowl
against the Ravens in the Superdome so
it's just the guys had big games in big
spots for big teams and nobody talks
about him because he's a guy who never
seeks the spotlight and never the spot
never seeks him or finds him he just
keeps ticking I mean he needs 1,500
yards to catch Walter Payton which at
his current clip would be maybe two more
years depending on which team gets him
and uses him minore or keeps him so it's
entirely possible that it could go
Emmitt and Frank Gore but right now in
terms of people who are you know living
members of the all-time rushing list
it's it's it's Emmitt and Frank Gore
right now
yeah and I agree I he's a hall-of-famer
not everybody is you know we always look
at the Hall of Fame and we go well as he
as good as this guy like every baseball
player is not as good as Babe Ruth but
that doesn't mean you're not a
hall-of-famer
not if Frank Gore is not Barry Sanders
he's not Emmitt Smith he's not Jim Brown
he's not Walter Payton but that doesn't
mean he can't be a hall-of-famer we get
we get caught up on these numbers in
comparisons and then we lose sight on
what somebody accomplished and I think
Frank Gore is a Hall of Famer and you
know another thing with this league it's
a copycat league or at least it feels
like that sometimes the greatest show on
turf everybody thought well let's see if
we can run an offense the way the Rams
were running it now you have Lamar
Jackson is Lamar Jackson gonna create a
copycat Lee are we gonna start looking
for Lamar Jackson in the draft because
of his success when maybe we wouldn't
have if we didn't have this MVP like
season I don't know DP I mean you could
make a case that Lamar is the copycat
he's just a copycat of Russell Wilson
and the copycat of dak he's the copycat
of I mean we could go on and on I mean
mahomes is even a guy that can run it a
little bit but obviously his no-look
throws and his Roger Federer type
uncorking of a shot that you don't see
coming
two yard passes are overshadow the
ability that you could do both I mean
you know and that these guys are all
eventually copycats of Vick it's just
that the issue with Lamar Jackson is it
doesn't appear like he could be
copycatted that he is such a genuine
article who has the ability to slice you
up and with his with his legs with and
and the fact that he he's the one that
delivers the head towards the end of the
run - and now we're seeing also his
ability to sidearm balls through a
needle throwing receivers open that way
I mean that that is that is next-level
stuff that we're not used to seeing out
of a second-year quarterback even though
we did see it out of last years MVP
under those circumstances so he's
playing as well as in my mind is mahomes
I mean he won't wind up with 50
touchdown passes but he should account
for about 40 when it's all said and done
he's pushing 30 I think in terms of
touchdowns accounted for
so um III think he is the guy but that
also has led to you know Kyle Emery I
mean we
he might push jaylen Hertz further up
the the the draft board of this coming
year but the question is is who can play
like Lamar I don't know
but that'll be certainly fun to find out
I think you're definitely seeing teams
believing that this is not only a
winnable format but sustainable and and
John Harbaugh man I mean this guy
changed streams last year Dan in the
middle of the year like if a Martian
came down from from from the heavens
last night and that was the first
football game at the Martian saw goes oh
wow that's that's the way quarterbacks
play nono quarterbacks don't play like
that as a matter of fact let's show you
the difference we would show them
footage of the guy he replaced in Joe
Flacco that's the footage we would show
and they did it midstream last year and
now with the full offseason man it's
just been dynamite to watch them and
and they also racked up 260 yards
rushing it's not just his arm I don't
know how this could be complicated but
you also have a situation and we went
back and looked at an article that a
report that he in Rappaport had it was
November 4th of last year John Harbaugh
was on the hot seat and and it was if
you don't make the postseason John
Harbaugh was probably going to be fired
and hear you because he made that change
and went to Lamar Jackson and that
changed the fortunes of this franchise
so you know let let's not make it seem
like John Harbaugh was on you know
stable footing here he know he went to
Lamar Jackson I think it was desperate
times depth desperate measures and he
bought in till tomorrow axon and as a
result you know he might be coach of the
year and Marv Jackson might be MVP
that's how quick summation yeah well I
mean remember Coughlin was on a hot seat
too and he decided you know I'm gonna
make a change I guess let maybe the foot
off the gas pedal within his own locker
room and and hand things off to his
veteran players and then suddenly boom
he wins the Super Bowl and then boom he
wins another one and we're talking about
him eventually maybe one day should he
be in the Hall of Fame I mean these
things in that way have happened before
and I guess just to put a button on it I
should mention Kaepernick I mean
Kaepernick is also a forerunner you know
of Lamar Jackson to the point where the
current coordinator of the Ravens was
Kaepernick's for another Harbaugh
against John in the Superbowl years ago
it really is a hole full circle
situation but again I just don't know
how Lamar Jackson can be different and
Kaepernick was that was that same guy in
a way where he was like an ATM a points
ATM you put the card in you just place
runner passion and the points and yards
came out back in 2012 we're kind of
seeing that again I mentioned the Rams
issues in the first hour because they do
have some issues here and they might not
make the playoffs and I think it's only
gonna get worse for this team because
you know Gurley is not in every down
back anymore I loved our Donald you know
do you you sign up jail and Ramsey they
have so much money that they've spent so
much of a cap hit and with Jared golf no
draft picks and you're gonna be moving
into that noose
I just don't think things get better for
the rims I think they get worse what do
you think I think in the same way that
we're we're talking about John Harbaugh
looking inward if you will or looking at
the pieces that he has but we'll see
what McVeigh does but it's hard to it's
hard to sit here and say that that
Belichick in a Super Bowl last year
didn't figure out if for the lack of
better phrase what the Rams were doing
their special sauce that had them one
year ago you want to talk about one year
ago this time we were talking about the
death of defense after the Rams and
Chiefs put up a hundred and 105 points
together on Monday night and since that
night the Rams really a offense hasn't
been the same I believe in Shaun McVeigh
to try and figure out what can be done
less meets needs a smart guy they have
pushed all their chips to the center of
the table on as the Rams organization
has on less and on Shaun and on golf and
girly and Donald and obviously jaylen
Ramsey as well they're smart enough to
try and figure out another way through
potentially but I think you're right
that the sands in the hourglass in 2019
are fast running out there too behind
the Vikings right now and and I don't
know how they bridge that gap this year
Rich Eisen the Rich Eisen show NFL
Network host the NFL will 100 all-time
team the defensive linemen and
linebackers who made the team will be
revealed this week finalists will be
revealed tonight on ESPN great to touch
base with you rich thank you you too
buddy and we'll talk soon okay thank you
it's Rich Eisen for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]